SOWMYA KANNAN: Hello.
Welcome to the Google Cloud
career readiness program.
Google Cloud has developed a
cloud engineer career readiness
path for students and
faculty in higher education.
Let's take a look at
the cloud landscape
and learn more about the
Associate Cloud Engineer Track.
Enterprises are
migrating to the cloud
and building new
applications on the cloud.
Leading industry research
indicates that a shift to cloud
will affect more than $1
trillion in IT spending.
Adoption of cloud-native
applications
will double by 2020.
This accelerated
move towards cloud
has created a tremendous demand
for qualified professionals,
who are proficient in
cloud technologies.
Traditional roles are evolving
in a cloud-first world.
For example, an app
developer or data analyst
needs new skills to succeed
with cloud technologies.
New roles related to
DevOps, data science,
and machine learning
are emerging.
You can kickstart your career
in cloud-related career paths.
Google's leading edge,
enterprise-ready curriculum
and learning
resources can help you
achieve industry-recognized
Associate Cloud Engineer
certification.
The Associate Cloud
Engineer Track
provides training free
of charge to prepare
for the Associate Cloud
Engineer certification exam.
This track includes
access to the Architecting
with Google Cloud Platform
specialization on Coursera.
This on-demand training
includes six in-depth courses,
with videos, hands-on
labs, and quizzes.
Hands-on experience
is crucial for success
with the Associate Cloud
Engineer certification exam.
You'll receive credits to
complete self-based labs
on the Qwiklabs
platform free of charge.
This training puts you
on the path to success
for achieving the Associate
Cloud Engineer certification.
Based on course completion
timelines and other criteria,
students receive a 50% discount
on the certification exam.
Familiarity with
the following topics
is helpful for success with
the Associate Cloud Engineer
Track--
operating systems, file systems,
the IP networking stack,
how web browsers and
web servers communicate,
databases, programming, working
with Linux at the command line,
and editing text files from
the Linux command line.
To participate in
this track, you'll
need a laptop or desktop
with the latest versions
of any popular web browser.
The Google Chrome
browser is recommended.
A robust internet connection
to access Google Cloud Platform
console is required.
Let's look at the training
in a bit more detail.
The Associate Cloud
Engineer Track
has two main
training components.
The Architecting with Google
Cloud Platform specialization
on Coursera covers
topics related
to exploring and deploying
solution elements,
including infrastructure
components,
such as networks, systems,
and application services.
The Cloud Architecture Quest
on the Qwiklabs platform
is a set of hands-on labs
that provide practice
on topics and services that
appear in the Associate Cloud
Engineer certification exam.
It's highly recommended that
you complete additional labs
as well.
The training you'll receive in
the Associate Cloud Engineer
Track provides a
solid foundation
for preparing to take
the certification exam.
However, the training does
not teach exactly what
you will need to pass the test.
Practical hands-on
experience is also needed.
Make sure to get hands-on
experience by practicing
with the suggested
labs in Qwiklabs
and to review product
documentation.
You'll earn a course completion
certificate from Google Cloud
upon completing the Coursera
specialization successfully.
Success in the Associate Cloud
Engineer certification exam
enables you to demonstrate
to potential employers
that you have the skills
necessary to succeed
in roles that
require proficiency
in cloud technologies.
The Associate Cloud
Engineer Track
must be completed in 16 weeks.
This slide shows a
suggested timeline.
Complete Architecting
with Google Cloud Platform
specialization within
the first 9 weeks.
Complete Cloud Architecture
Quest and other hands-on labs
by week 16.
Your access to Coursera will
expire at the end of 16 weeks.
Practice for the
certification exam,
and complete the exam before
the voucher expiration date.
Remember, you can race ahead
of the suggested timeline.
Let's now take a quick look at
the Student Resource Center.
The Student Resource Center
includes FAQs, as well as
Study Jam materials
for extra practice.
To clarify, Study Jams
are essentially workshops.
If you're not able to meet other
students in a workshop setting,
you can work through the Study
Jam materials on your own,
as well.
If you have questions about the
Associate Cloud Engineer Track,
check the FAQs and the support
section for information.
Happy learning.